[Música]
y la pérdida de la visión periférica es
una afección que disminuye el campo
visual
según las ciencias médicas
oftalmológicas está asociada a una
retinitis pigmentaria a una retinopatía
diabética o un glaucoma
por supuesto que yo no soy médico
pero si tuviese que agregar algo a esa
lista también agregaría a la escuela
tradicional
el colegio mayormente pone el foco en el
desarrollo individual si bien
compartimos con otros un aula un espacio
una materia un docente estudiamos de
nuestro propio libro
nos exigen incorporar información para
ser evaluados individualmente
y a partir de esas evaluaciones
anotarlas en nuestra libreta personal
convivimos y aprendemos en un espacio de
materias individuales matemáticas
físicas historia lenguas y sufrimos
generalmente el egoísmo de los docentes
que nos dicen mi materia es la más
importante
cuando llegamos a la facultad eso no
cambia generalmente somos estimulados
con estímulos que son muy pocos
colaborativos y vamos siempre en
búsqueda del éxito personal cuando
termine la facultad y estudiar eeuu e
irlanda y españa quería aprender todos
los métodos actualizados para aplicar en
mi trabajo pero también tener mayores
ventajas comparativas al momento de ir
por la búsqueda de un empleo durante
mucho tiempo me paré con la postura de
recibir información retenerla y
aplicarla en mi trabajo
esas acciones durante los primeros 10
años me dieron muchísimos resultados
ese desarrollo individual esa
adquisición de conocimientos técnicos y
una obsesión por la organización me
hicieron que tenga un gran
reconocimiento profesional pero todo eso
tenía un propósito y el propósito era
que quería ser el mejor
un día sonó mi celular era un llamado de
la unión argentina de rugby
me estaban convocando a una entrevista
con agustín pichot ex capitán de los
pumas y máximo referente del plan de
alto rendimiento
cuando tuve esa reunión a un tipo
concreto me dijo vas a entrenar a los
pumas pero necesitamos dos cosas mejorar
la organización y que más personas
aprendan lo que vos sabes
entrada a los pumas era mi sueño y era
para lo que me había preparado toda la
vida pero porque tenía que compartir mi
conocimiento
porque tenía que colaborar con los demás
para que sean mejores
me ha costado mucho aprender había
invertido mucho dinero y tal vez si más
personas aprendían lo que yo sabía el
día de mañana me podían reemplazar por
ellos
al poco tiempo ingreso al plan como
asesor graham henry
graham henry fue el entrenador y uno de
los precursores de un cambio cultural en
los all blacks el equipo nacional de
rugby de nueva zelanda ese cambio los
llevó a ganar el campeonato del mundo
luego de 24 años de frustraciones y
repetirlo al mundial siguiente
graham en una de las primeras reuniones
que tuve con él me dijo
los estuve viendo trabajar son muy
buenos en lo que hacen pero si lo que
ustedes saben queda solamente retenido
en este equipo y en este staff no sirve
para nada no estaban buscando que los
entrenamientos sean tan buenos ni
tampoco lograr un resultado épico lo que
querían crear en un sistema
había llegado el momento después de que
entendí la idea de cambiar mi foco de
ser alguien que recibía información y la
retenía para beneficio personal pasar a
alguien que recibía información y la
derramaba para el crecimiento del
deporte en definitiva yo soy profesor de
educación física y la raíz de ese título
es la docencia
simbólicamente me regalaron un par de
lentes y me dijeron te toca hacer una
tarea muy difícil
vas a tener que ir y ver cómo reaccionan
y cuáles son las conductas de las
personas que trabajan en una
organización por lo tanto cuando hayas
pones estos anteojos te va a permitir
mejorar tu campo visual y a su vez
detectar el déficit de visión periférica
que tienen la mayoría de las personas
me puse esos anteojos y emprendí el
camino
qué es lo que veo cuando voy por
distintas organizaciones en el país
viendo lo que pasa
si a las personas nos dejan organizarnos
de manera espontánea actuamos con las
mismas conductas en la escuela
tradicional compartimos un momento
compartimos un espacio pero somos poco
colaborativos tenemos tendencia a
agruparnos por islas ponemos nos
nuestros intereses personales por encima
de los demás y siempre queremos
sobresalir del resto
el deporte no es la excepción cuántos
clubes creen que hay adentro de un mismo
club
tantos clubes como entrenadores aia
los entrenadores por criterio personal o
por intereses desarrollan su propio
método de entrenamiento eligen su propio
modelo de juego y establecen sus propias
normas disciplinarias hacen de su equipo
su propio club y cuando los chicos pasan
de categoría o cambian de categoría
también cambian de club se van al club
del nuevo entrenador lo bueno es que por
lo menos mantienen la misma camiseta que
representa la institución
entonces lo que es un año y con un
entrenador estaba bien
al año siguiente está mal lo que un
entrenador estimulaba el otro prohíbe si
a un entrenador le gustan los sistemas
ofensivos al otro le gustan los sistemas
defensivos
tal vez mientras yo estoy diciendo esto
cada uno piense día pero martín uno está
diciendo entonces que la diversidad no
es buena no no estoy diciendo eso la
diversidad es muy buena y la diversidad
es lo mejor que nos puede pasar para
poder aprender
la diversidad es buena siempre y cuando
esté organizada sino la heterogeneidad
que genera esa diversidad del único modo
que agrega valor
y si está en función del objetivo
pedagógico de la institución no del
capricho de un entrenador de entrenador
de su ignorancia o de sus intereses
otra cosa que le pasa a las
organizaciones
contar entre sus filas con aquellos que
dicen este este que me va a enseñar si
hace 20 años que hago esto que te puede
enseñar y ni hablar de aquellas
organizaciones que cuentan con personas
que retienen su conocimiento que no
están dispuestas a entregarlo tal como
hacía yo esa era mi conducta
y no entregamos ese conocimiento porque
eso es lo que nos da poder eso es lo que
nos hace o creemos que nos hace valiosos
pero si a eso le sumamos que trabajamos
de manera aislada y compitiendo entre
nosotros esas organizaciones no tienen
ninguna posibilidad de evolucionar la
mezquindad de conocimiento genera una
pobreza institucional enorme
una vez un amigo que andaba por acá
me dijo si quieres aprender mucho sobre
un tema anda a hablar con el que
escribió el libro sobre ese tema y a
cada pregunta que vos le hagas te va a
dar respuestas detalladas se va a tomar
el tiempo para poder contestarte
y se va a asegurar que en el momento que
termine la reunión pues hayas aprendido
pero si hablas con quien leyó el libro
probablemente no te diga ni a dónde lo
compró o quiere ser el único en realidad
que conoce ese contenido
eso es algo que habitualmente sucede
y esa mezquindad de conocimiento genera
que también las organizaciones esta
empresas de lo que nosotros llamamos la
teoría del superhéroe entonces cuando la
organización no está pasando un buen
momento y le va mal vamos a buscar a
alguien que nos pueda salvar entonces
contratamos a superman viene superman y
si no tiene resultados le damos una
patada le arrancamos la capa y lo
tiramos a la hoguera total ahora vamos
en búsqueda de batman y si batman no
tiene resultado también le quitamos el
antifaz y sigue el mismo camino y eso
sucede tantas veces como sea necesario
hasta que encontremos a aquella persona
que nos dé éxito cuando eso sucede le
otorgamos un poder mesiánico por
habernos permitido ganar un campeonato
pero no nos damos cuenta que siempre hay
una organización de mucho mayor poder
económico que la nuestra
entonces como también está en búsqueda
un superar un superhéroe se lo lleva y
ahí quedamos de nuevo en la organización
tratando de encontrar un salvador
al que vamos a tirar a la hoguera porque
vamos a volver a endiosar las
instituciones pierden muchísimo dinero
con las teorías de los superhéroes y
generalmente o mayormente nunca dan
resultado la manera de poder
contrarrestar estas conductas
personalistas que yo les acabo de
describir es creando sistemas educativos
las organizaciones
deportivas empresariales políticas que
logran tener resultados por más tiempo o
que crecen año tras año son aquellas que
trascienden a las personas
desde que me puse esos anteojos
recorrí en la argentina a lo largo ya lo
ancho en tres deportes distintos de
fútbol y básquet
y mi concepto de que es el mejor cambio
por completo antes yo pensaba que los
mejores eran los que más sabían hoy creo
que los mejores son quienes desarrollan
sistemas educativos de colaboración
hay que tener dos voluntades para poder
ser parte de un sistema la voluntad de
aprender sabiendo que es mucho más lo
que ignoramos que lo que sabemos por lo
tanto en cualquier momento o de
cualquier persona podemos aprender
y la voluntad de compartir el
conocimiento
la voluntad de compartir el conocimiento
permite que cualquier organización puede
extraer de nuestra cabeza todo lo que
nosotros sabemos y lo pueda redactar en
un documento vivo que se transforme en
un activo institucional y a partir de
eso en la organización ya no sabe ya no
importa quién sabe más lo que importa es
que el sistema sabe más
por lo tanto si la institución tiene que
ir a buscar a un superhéroe
no importa si gano pierde no importa si
se lo llevan o se queda por un tiempo
determinado si abre su cabeza y nos
permite que su conocimiento quede
redactado en ese documento se habrá
enriquecido al sistema
no traje 4000 pares de lentes para poder
compartir con ustedes pero a través de
esta charla
lo que quiero es colaborar para que
podamos ampliar nuestra visión
periférica y tal vez podemos dejar de
pensar que nos va a salvar un superhéroe
un deportista un entrenador un ministro
de economía o un presidente
yo me comprometí a desarrollar sistemas
y hacer que se cumplan los invito a que
cada uno de nosotros tengamos la
voluntad de enriquecer los sistemas de
los que somos parte
y exijamos que se respeten
tal vez así podamos lograr que las
instituciones crezcan y que nuestro país
no tenga que empezar de cero todos los
días muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]